out of Downing Street back in Ukraine a
popular face in Kiev but at home
controversy once again surrounds Boris
Johnson with allegations he took a loan
guarantee of up to 800 000 pounds from a
distant cousin to fund living costs
while in number 10 and this man former
banker and Tori donor Richard Sharp
helped arrange it weeks before he was
recommended as chair of the BBC
countless questions but from this Ally
of Boris Johnson few answers I've not
had a conversation with either of those
parties about that about that situation
I have met with Richard we uh discussed
the World Service he struck me as an
incredibly competent experienced
thoughtful uh individual so what
happened according to the Sunday Times
Canadian millionaire Sam Blythe
suggested the loan guarantee during
dinner with Richard Sharp Richard Sharp
then a pro approached the cabinet
secretary sharp and Blythe met with
Boris Johnson for dinner at his
Countryside residence Checkers but they
insist his finances were not discussed
then Weeks Later the government
announced Richard Sharp As the preferred
candidate for BBC chair
the BBC said it had no role in picking
its chair while the government said a
rigorous appointments process was
followed labor now wants that reviewed
though and a parliamentary probe
launched Richard Sharp also denied a
conflict of interest saying he just
connected people chairman of the BBC is
an enormously important one for the
country and you want the process for
appointing a new person to be absolutely
squeaky clean and I think there are some
real questions to be answered in this
instance
questions 2 for the former prime
minister spokesman for Boris Johnson
said everything was properly declared
that he didn't get any Financial advice
off Richard Sharp and didn't give him
any compensation on the checkers meeting
the spokesman said he did have dinner
with Mr Sharp someone he's known for
almost 20 years and with his cousin but
added so what big deal
have you been honest about your tax
Affairs Mr zahawi but one deal we know
has been done the Tory chairman Nadim
zahawi has confirmed he had to settle an
unpaid tax bill the amount is still on
no no as is whether he was being looked
into while still Chancellor there are
big problem states in the country we
need good government and I think it's it
would be a tragedy if the result of all
this was for people to just simply turn
away from politics and say they're all a
bunch of crooks and knives no longer in
power but still Making Waves The Curious
Case of the Prime Minister the
businessman and the BBC chair awkward
for all involved political damage that
could reach further afield Rob palski
news in Westminster